the whole idea of what we're trying to
do is think think deeply about this very
very simple thing something you've been
looking at for years literally by this
point right now where did we end
yesterday we had the discriminant your
honor talk about the distributor what
happens if just women's negative namely
negative negative description no real
roots or a real risk whatever that means
if the discriminant is exactly equal to
0 what do you get you guys to get a
single one double root or you get two
roots that are equal to each other or of
course the the normal situation of where
the discriminates positive which is just
two roots and they are separate okay so
what I want us to do is I'm on the back
of this minus B plus or minus and I'm
just gonna write the discriminant these
are our two solutions for our two roots
right I want you to push on this a
little bit to try and understand
specifically the roots we've been
looking at the roots of the coordinate
for a long time
in fact they're one of the first things
that you learn how to find the idea I
thought from here is that they're
related to each other right they're not
just like here in somewhere anyway you'd
like let's assume everyone is you
necessarily know where the other one is
so I want to push on the relationship
between them to help us do that we're
just going to name them and the
traditional name for one root is alpha
and what is beat up
so alpha will call that the first one
the one to the left so that's going to
be the negative case square root and
that gives you beta which is the
positive case
okay now what I'm interested in is this
relationship between the roots I can see
when I look at these two things because
they're so similar in fact they have a
special name these things are called
conjugates
you might remember conjugates from what
you had to rationalize the denominator
of you know a fraction we had something
like a square root on the bottom okay so
if I asked you to rationalize this what
would you multiply the top of the bottom
by your mother but in this case you
multiply by its square root of five but
plus two right so that on the top and
that on the bottom and the reason why
conjugates are really useful is because
here you take advantage of what
algebraic properties my relative
difference it just fits very good you
got a minus B a plus B it all comes out
in the wash okay over here you've got
exactly the same kind of thing right so
being that I see that kind of pattern
and multiplying will give something
useful here I want to think about well
what would happen if I multiply these
two things together I now I know exactly
what they're equal to so there would be
this there's one and I would multiply by
no not and because of difference of
squares I ought to expect something
simple at the end okay now I'm gonna
pause this we can work this out it's not
that hard maybe takes any how many lines
was it maybe three or four lines
something like that yeah so again like
we said because of this feature it's not
hard okay
but as you'll see why in a second I'm
gonna do something different let's just
pause there for a minute this is what we
called the the product every one times
the other right difference you can label
that in the other useful thing which
also takes advantage of the fact that
they're conjugates is not the product of
roots when you multiply but the sum of
roots which is when you add the sum of
roots
for the exact same reason before that we
said yes it's a conjugate right you're
going to expect when you write this
thing out - B - what plus you ought to
expect just like before there should be
some very radical cancelling out right
you expecting earth I look at these two
guys see because they're exact offices
what's gonna happen when you put it all
together if I add 5 and subtract 5 from
something you have a net effect of
nothing right these two guys are like
you know matter/antimatter they're gone
okay so this will become a very simple
thing but rather than take this kind of
brute force approach to doing it I want
to imagine something different okay so
we're gonna get these same results but
I'm going to show it to you and I think
are more insightful another good way
okay
so underneath way you've written this
write the following can sit up a
quadratic and at the moment all I know
about it like a B and C it completely
who knows what they are they're
completely entertainment but all I know
is the roots are half bar and be like
that's what I'm calling okay so if the
roots of a quadratic are alpha and beta
right we looked at this guy before what
are the roots of this equation minus 2
and minus 3 right so in other words it's
just the opposite of things I could have
written it like this X minus minus 2
there's one root and X minus minus 3
there's the other bridge okay so if I
know that the roots are from Veta then a
quadratic with roots x equals alpha x
equals b 9 is of the form
now you remember we talked about forms
yesterday we talked about general form
which gives us this we talked about
vertex form I'm saying that there are
roots to this thing so therefore we
should be able to go straight to a
factorized form
right that's a factorized form what
would go in there remember the boots
Alfred Oh X minus X minus beta X - what
if the roots X minus the other root okay
so this thing has roots alpha beta okay
it's one of the quadratics the hazards
alpha and beta there are others how do I
take them into account yeah good if I
don't have this a what keep told me
about the quadratic it's it's Manik very
good and we have no trouble with monix
but mics are only one kind there are
loads of other ones if it's negative you
have upside-down ones so that's the
brother right but I should know as well
that I can write it in the form of
camera fall right in fact I can do more
than just set their equal I can say
these should always be equal right I
want you to think back to when we did or
observe the angle remember auxiliary
angle right we said something like this
if you add together two wave functions
remember how we were this the sum of two
wave functions is itself a wave function
remember that except it's bigger like
the amplitude is bigger and the the
phase has been moved over a little bit
right and so our conclusion is this you
Chuck a number at the front to change
the amplitude and then how do we account
for the face what did we do thanks for
seven which is where the name comes from
auxilary angle there is right there so
I'm doing exactly the same thing here
I'm looking at one object from two
angles you see that one object two
angles and when we do the last time we
gained some insight same things gonna
happen here so let's start off this guy
here I can expand out right what's this
gonna be when I extend it first time
there's gonna be four times right yep
next time
- yes - so I'm gonna go those - then
those - yeah - betta X so I've dealt
with him now I'll come into here good
and to finish off good okay now just
pause for a second before I go any
further do you see why I'm going this
direction tucked into this expansion the
sum and product of roots do you see them
the product is a bit obvious it's right
there the sum is hidden but it's there
as well okay all right now to see how
I've got this in a particular form is
out the front right he's not at the
front of this but I can make it at the
front I put a out the front there what's
going to be left in brackets okay so I'm
gonna get x squared that's fine
what's gonna happen here this is going
to be B on a right because I've divided
all these tones by a factor that out you
care with that doesn't this seem
familiar from when we did completing the
square to get the quadratic formula plus
what's on the end see you name it okay
now pause for a second a is just a
constant it can't be zero because
otherwise I don't have a quadratic right
so since it can't be zero I can divide
through by a you're happy without any if
it was equal to zero you can't divide
through by it because dividing by zero
makes things go haywire okay so I stick
this one equal zero and then I divide
through now as I divide through I'm
gonna neaten this guy up over here okay
put a minus sign there then that's how
many X's I've got you care with that
just make that really clear there's all
the X terms
right so I've I've tied them up in a
nice neat bow I've got alpha beta on the
end and then I divided through by a over
here so this is all I have left
okay yeah again think back to when you
were doing auxiliary angle right we're
doing this okay we expanded this guy
we've got a few things here and then the
rabbit out of a hat moment is where we
saw that these things and these things
be talking about the same thing right
have a look here are my X Squared's no
big deal of course there's the same
thing on both sides no surprises there
but when you look at your X terms right
I have this many X terms on the left
hand side and I have this many X terms
on the right hand side where else can
the X's come from it's up nowhere
there's no other external found so those
two must be equal and in exactly the
same way this is the constant term right
there's no other closer terms on the
left hand side and this is the constant
term on the right hand side there's no
other constants there's nowhere else I
could make up the constants from okay so
now I have my sum and product two roots
are you ready okay let's go green and
green minus alpha plus beta that's the
whole thing don't forget sign is be on a
so it'll be a little bit neater I'll
check that negative over the other side
just before I leave that does that not
make sense have a look at this here
watch the sum is very easy to compute
you already told me that these two
things would cancel bam bam right so
you've got minus B minus B and then
you've got to lay on the denominator
bam bam there you go is Arizona and in
exactly the same way by comparing
coefficients in fact that's probably
what happens it by comparing
coefficients
I also have that product of roots right
see on a full stop and if you want to
you can go ahead you can multiply this
out and sure enough that's what
abilities